welcome back to 8701 so we continue our
discussion on the
feynman calculus and continue now
talking about fermi's golden rule
the heart of calculating decay weight
and cross-section
is from his golden rule and it simply
tells you how we can use the calculation
of amplitudes and the available phase
space
to make um assessment of rates decay
rates and cross sections
so the amplitude m uh holds all the
dynamic
information and we can we'll see that we
can calculate
um the amplitude by evaluating final
diagrams directly using
5 min rules the available phase space
holds is a kinematic factor and it
depends on masses
on the energies and the momentum of the
particle involved and then again
thermos golden rule simply says that the
transition
rates or decay weights and cross
sections are given by the product of the
phase space
and the square of the amplitude now this
how does this now look like if we look
at the golden rule for the case
here we suppose having one particle
decaying into
a second third fourth nth particle you
see that the
decay rate is given by
the matrix element the amplitude squared
and the term which is the um
the phase base factor there's also a
factor here in front
this s has to account we have to account
for the fact that we might have
the same particle in the final state or
multiple the same particle current
multiple times
and we have to make sure that we don't
have double counting and this double
counting has to be corrected
if all particles are different this
extra factor is
is one we'll look at this some more
later
now at first glance this looks like
rather complicated but if you try to
assess now
what those individual terms mean you'll
see that it's very accessible so
when we try to calculate or use
from this golden rule for the case we
have to
integrate over all outgoing particle for
momenta
but we have three kinematical
constraints
the first one is that the outgoing
particles
have to be unmasked so they have to be
on mars shell
we talked about this this issue of
virtual
visual or particle and mass shell before
but simply they have to
the energy of the particle has to follow
this condition
this is a delta function which simply
means that this
you know this gives us if the argument
is is zero
the delta function returns one the
argument is nonzero
then the function returns zero so this
rather simplifies
uh this term here so this first part
here
um in in our in our premise golden rule
simply accounts for the fact that
outgoing particles have to be
on mass shell um outgoing particles also
have to have positive
energies and this explains our second
factor here this factor and so this
vector
um is the heavy side function and this
is simply
zero for negative values and one for
positive values
and the last one means that energy and
momentum of the particle have to
conserve so the first particle
minus the second third and so on for
each of the component
for the for energy and for the three
components of the
of the momentum have to be um zero for
this to return one
so again another delta function there's
also vectors of pi
and the simple rule here is for each
delta function you have to account for a
vector of two pi
in your function so this basically
explains already
everything we see here on the slide
so now we can calculate and i recommend
to have a look at griffith chapter 6 for
this
if you look at two particle decays so
one particle
into two particles this simplifies quite
tremendously
because of all the delta functions here
and the heavy side functions this
equation
simplifies directly to a factor
you have the momentum of the particle
here and a matrix element
again you have this statistical factor
here to account for the fact that
there might be duplicates and then you
know you want to keep
the track of the statistical factor
um for scattering the equation looks
almost the same so you have the same
um the same phase base factor almost the
same face back
factor matrix element again this is the
transition rate is given by
as thermic golden rules tells us by the
matrix element squared
and the phase based vector this overall
factors we'll look at later
um they're slightly different um but
here as a rule we just want to you know
make sure that we
we have a way to access ss cross
sections that this makes sense
we'll see later in more detail
for two body decays in the center of
mass frame
you know that the initial momentum in
the center of mass frames
of particle one and particles to have to
be the same
the outgoing momenta also have to be the
same they don't necessarily have to be
the same as the in-game method
but when you use this uh the
differential cross-section then
can be calculated um quite
quite straightforwardly again with the
matrix element squared
we have the final state momentum the
initial state momenta
and divide this by the sum of the energy
squared
together with a as an extra factor here
so what we have seen here is just we
have looked at it i didn't explain
how we got to this um but we have seen
from this golden rule which helps us to
assess
and we have seen how we can actually
calculate um the phase of this factor
in the next lecture please now see how
we can calculate
the matrix element itself and we'll
start doing this by using a toy
experiment or a toy model such that the
discussion simplifies
algebra simplifies quite a bit